Speaker 1: There is
Speaker 2: just an incredible
Speaker 1: new chapter
Speaker 2: in the
Speaker 1: Trump riot investigation.
I don't even know where to start setting this
up.
There was a riot on January 6th.
It was Trump supporters.
Hundreds of them are now in the legal system
as their cases go through the process.
There is an investigative committee investigating
what happened.
It's a House of Representatives committee
and there have now
Speaker 2: been revealed, per
Speaker 1: Liz Cheney text messages
Speaker 2: sent.
Listen to this
Speaker 1: from Fox News hosts to Donald Trump's
former chief of staff, Mark Meadows.
The texts are remarkable because they expose
no one how close the connection was between
Fox hosts
Speaker 2: and Trump's inner circle, which
we knew.
Speaker 1: But it reinforces that.
But no to the content of the texts that Laura
Ingraham sent to
Speaker 2: Mark Meadows, that
Speaker 1: Sean Hannity sent to Mark Meadows,
that Don Jr. set to Mark Meadows.
Why is Don Jr. texting Meadows instead of
calling Trump?
Well, Trump once claimed his wife calls him
sir.
That probably tells you a lot about his relationship
with his own kids.
The texts confirm that all of them knew it
was Trump
Speaker 2: supporters, and they
Speaker 1: knew it looked really, really bad
Speaker 2: and their lies.
Speaker 1: Later, they knew were lies.
Let me give you some examples.
Laura Ingraham
Speaker 2: texted to Mark Meadows
Speaker 1: on January 6th, according to Liz
Cheney quote, Trump needs to tell people in
the Capitol to go home.
This is hurting all of us.
He is destroying his legacy.
If it were antifa or BLM rioting on January
6th, Laura Ingram wouldn't have
Speaker 2: been saying that she knows the
truth
Speaker 1: of what happened.
However, that night on her program, Laura
Ingram leads with a story about Antifa role
in the Trump riots suggests that there were
provocateurs.
Speaker 2: This was not genuine
Speaker 1: Trumpists
Speaker 2: genuinely rioting, rioting.
They were provoked,
Speaker 1: and she suggests it was just three
dozen people who participated, although she
was corrected by Kevin McCarthy on her show.
Speaker 2: Wow, so
Speaker 1: you're saying she knew she was
lying?
Yes.
Speaker 2: The texts prove it.
Speaker 1: Next example Brian Kilmeade is
one of the hosts of that wacky morning show,
Fox and Friends Brian Kilmeade wrote to Mark
Meadows quote, Please get him on TV destroying
everything you have
Speaker 2: accomplished and then
Speaker 1: kill me.
Played up every lie about what happened to
Speaker 2: diminish and to
Speaker 1: downplay the seriousness of it.
Sean Hannity, a known friend of Trump to the
extent Trump has friends, wrote to Mark Meadows.
Speaker 2: Can he make a statement?
Speaker 1: Ask people to leave the Capitol?
And then Hannity proceeded to downplay it
all.
For months, hosting people who claimed it
was antifa and on and on, he knew it was all
a lie.
He was there texting on Jan. six, saying This
is bad is really bad.
Other text messages were sent to Mark Meadows
by Don Jr., Don Jr. wrote to Mark Meadows.
He's got to condemn this s ASAP.
The Capitol Police tweet is not enough.
Imagine having to go through your dad's chief
of staff because he's too hardheaded or doesn't
care enough about your opinion to actually
listen
Speaker 2: to you directly.
Speaker 1: And Meadows wrote back, I'm pushing
it hard.
I agree.
Trump then wrote back to Mark Meadows and
said, We need an Oval Office address.
He has the lead now.
It's gone too far and
Speaker 2: gotten out of hand.
But now
Speaker 1: Don Jr. just tells lie after, lie
after lie about what he supposedly believes
took place
Speaker 2: on that day.
He knows exactly
Speaker 1: what happened on that day, and
they've been lying all along.
So there are two stories here.
One.
All these people did see it for what it is,
and they're just lying to Trump right now.
And I'm sorry, and they're lying on the air
right now and then secondly, look at the people
who have direct lines to Trump's chief of
staff, the relationship between Fox News and
that administration really something to behold.
Speaker 2: So every day
Speaker 1: we are learning about more and
more
Speaker 2: lies, more
and
Speaker 1: more deception.